California congressman Adam Schiff is
the ranking Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee he is urging
Chairman Devin Nunes to reschedule the
open hearing with former acting Attorney
General Sally Yates Conklin Shipp joins
us from Washington good morning good
morning Charlie you have any evidence
that the White House urged and took part
in denying the opportunity for the Sally
Yates to testify I don't have any
particular evidence the time we
certainly raises a lot of questions and
the fact that the caring was canceled
abruptly and without an explanation
you know caused us a lot to ask you know
what's going on here why aren't we going
forward with this hearing I have to
think that you know the hearing that we
had on Monday of last week in which the
FBI director acknowledged for the first
time that the Trump campaign Associates
were under investigation for possible
coordination with Russia and the fact
that the directors rebutted the White
House claims about illegal wiretapping
by Barack Obama had something to do with
the cancellation the second open hearing
I think the White House probably felt
that didn't go well for them but it's
otherwise hard to explain why the sudden
cancellation of the hearing and I think
it probably had a lot to do with Sally
aides do you believe that the White
House is cooperating with the Chairman
and therefore robbing this committee of
credibility well you know I think there
is a close relationship that the
chairman has to the White House he was
an important member of the transition
team and I think he's maintained that
relationship with the White House and
that has caused a lot of questions to be
raised about whether he can fairly and
impartially lead this investigation the
events of last week I think called that
so seriously into question that he
really ought to recuse himself in
particular if he's raising an issue
about whether members of the transition
team were incidentally collected he was
a member of that team and I think
there's a real conflict of interest so I
think it would be in the best interest
the investigation going forward if
somewhere else on the committee were to
lead it but we really need to get this
back on track and I think the majority
can start out by rescheduling this here
and we've urged them to do that but we
have yet to hear back congressman let's
talk about the substance about perhaps
he wanted to hear from Sally Yates she
was the acting Attorney General she
informed the White House Council that
their National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn had made comments that
were perhaps untruthful what did you
want to hear directly from her well I
certainly wanted to hear the events that
led up to Michael Flynn's firing and
what has concerned me about this for
some time is according to newspaper
accounts she brought information to the
White House that indicated that Mike
Flynn had lied about a conversation he
had with a Russian ambassador and not
just about any topic this was on this
subject apparently at least according to
reports of the sanctions that President
Obama imposed on Russia over Russia's
interference in the election to help
Donald Trump so that's obviously a very
significant conversation it led to his
firing when he misled the vice president
and the vice president misled the
country but you have a period of some
time it looks like weeks in which the
president was aware that Michael Flint
had lied and the Vice President had
misrepresent the country misrepresented
the events to the country and the
president did nothing about it it was
only a White House Council didn't inform
the president of that conversation with
the acting Attorney General I would
certainly like to know I have to expect
that the White House Counsel did inform
the president and the question is why
didn't the president act why was the
president content to have the country
mislead about this secret conversation
and only took action with mr. Flynn
after it was brought out in public by
the Washington Post that suggests that
the real crime here was the publication
of mr. Flynn's lie not the fact that the
country was mislead and I think those
facts were facts the White House did not
want to come out in this open hearing
and the timing certainly raised a lot of
questions about whether the White House
preference had a lot to do with changing
where this investigation was headed well
congressman Schiff think you were at a
time but we do have more more questions
for you so we hope you'll return and I'm
sure